all right so there's this rapper
i think this is like maryland this is
like one of the most insane things i've
ever seen
he oh
he's a rapper gu knew yeah he got shot
like two weeks ago
r.i.p
and
he passed away and like basically like
his family or like his friends got
together and they threw his like funeral
in a club
and they took his body like his corpse
and like basically embalmed it dressed
him in full amiri
and then put him in the club with
everyone partying
so he's hysterical he's just posted up
in the corner and like everyone's there
like legit going crazy
that's fire
[Music]
wow yeah that's wild
[Music]
yeah that's wild
i mean kind of crazy
damn i mean
but also looking fly as [ __ ] i don't
know what if somebody bumped a table
apparently i i just read this i don't
know it was true but like towards the
end like
the state of his embalming wasn't as
good like they were going for like five
six hours so like his jaw was like sewn
shut like locked shut and it slowly
started to like open up like
it turned into a thing they had to get
like the embalmer to come back and like
because he's standing up he was just
trying to that's gravity yeah
he's trying to get his bars off
i mean yeah it's wild kind of wild
though but maybe it is is it wild to
like is it open casket wild that's what
i'm saying how different is this than an
open casket yeah slightly
yeah yeah i guess the open casket like
the people that you know but think of
how much money you save not having a
casket that's thousands of dollars right
there bang that goes for it fire dj some
drinks but also he might know all these
people these might just be like his
family and friends yeah it is right i
assume it's just people it's an irish
wake but it's more fun it was like yeah
it wasn't like a club night like i think
they rented out the club and like did
the yeah yeah so this is their version
of it i think that's i think it's cool
like it just makes me think about how
odd the
the open casket is
yeah have you have you done that before
and i have that's just not weird i
laughed my [ __ ] ass off no
one of my best friend's dad no yeah yeah
this is the craziest thing it's the
insane take right say again it's just a
wild taste you know he saw one of his
friends and it was like andrew and alex
type of thing it's like a silent library
thing like
[ __ ] and it was like i knew i wasn't
supposed to laugh so i started laughing
and it was like
it's like somebody looks at you and goes
do not laugh
right like i walked in the room and i
was like yeah you just don't laugh no
matter what and then uh yes well who was
the friend come on right now who was the
friend you were looking at and
challenging i didn't honestly i might
have been i might have been alone
probably nils no definitely not bills
but like it was yeah but i remember
having i was like oh [ __ ] and i had to
leave so i could go outside and [ __ ]
laugh dude
that's the most [ __ ] thing i've ever
heard it's bad right like it's it sounds
[ __ ] up but crazy i know it's not
crazy no thank god i'm gonna outlive you
dog because i don't want you laughing at
my [ __ ] funeral no i would laugh at
your funeral that'd be fine seeing your
little flabby body
sitting down there spilling all over the
coffin
no dude be funny yeah it'd be funny no i
think we should yeah we're definitely
gonna have jokes did you see that irish
guy's funeral i thought that was dope uh
or when they is the funeral the same as
when they bury you
is the funeral the same as when they
bury you there's a service and then
sometimes like it's at the grave site
sometimes it's out yeah so the one that
was at the gravesite because usually i
think the irish people do like a wake is
called a wake wake where they it's like
in a a place it's in the funeral home
right that [ __ ] is so fire bro okay
this [ __ ] made me want to die
oh no
watch this this is great so they're at
this dude's funeral you gotta turn the
volume way up though
let's go ahead
[Music]
hello
hello
[Music]
oh
[Music]
shout out to the audio mixer like yeah
oh they did a great job right
wait so what are you going to do for
yourself i don't know i don't want to
plan it because i think we'll make it
happen but like
i just think that that is so cool like
he's aware that all these people are
going to be sad on this day and then he
gets and in a weird way maybe it makes
you even more emotional you're like i
really miss this guy he was really good
yeah makes me way sadder yeah at the
same time you want everyone to cry at
your funeral right facts
i don't know what a cool moment like
that's why i saved you for the end
they're crying and then you just lift
their spirits there it is that's how you
leave there it is that isn't that cool
and the dopest thing about it is
it
laughs can be selfish right yeah it
makes himself laugh you feel good he's
gone
that is selflessness yeah and laughter
you're giving somebody the laugh and
you're not there to take it you gotta
think what if that [ __ ] bombs
yeah
like you died you gotta try it out you
you're gonna throw it in someone else's
fury
though because to bomb and to not have
to deal with the bomb
imagine you bombed and you died right
after the set and you never have to
imagine your kids are there and all of a
sudden they're like yo my dad died and
then he sucked at jokes like the [ __ ]
imagine no one showed
and it's just the guy
that looks after the cemetery
and he's burying you in the [ __ ]
cassette starts to play
and he doesn't know
i'm in the box
he's prying that thing open 100
oh yeah yeah that [ __ ] i don't know that
was cool yeah that's far i think that
was stupid i'm not doing that i'm
getting cremated you're getting cremated
yeah really i don't want my body in
there huh i don't want my body i mean
even way more fire video if it it's hot
[Laughter]
turn the [ __ ] fire off yeah wait you
really are getting cremated that's not
very catholic yeah yeah i'm surprised
y'all do that i don't know both my
grandparents got cremated are they
catholic yeah
aren't y'all not supposed to do that
we're supposed to do that oh really yeah
are you on that i don't know i didn't
know there was a rule against it i gotta
ask yeah you definitely can't get
cremated dude why not you're gonna get
your ashes
i'm not gonna give them spread i'm gonna
get to put an iron and buried
that's super gay why
it's also cheaper too it's also cheaper
it's a smaller plot yeah less plot yeah
i mean ah
what you're gonna get your ashes and
then bury the ashes getting buried is
weird though why the whole casket and
all that like for what
that's weird like for what no it's
better why well what if you actually do
have to lay like that for the rest of
your you know eternity but you're buried
anyway just burn me yeah you want to be
ash just piled up are you going to do
this whole ganges river thing hell yeah
bruh burn you on the planet yeah
what is
like all the bodies get put on uh no you
get cremated yeah and my wife because
she can outlive me because she nagged me
so much she's gonna fly to india spread
my ashes in the ganga and then i'm out
wait that's actually a thing yeah can we
go
no you think that they're going to let a
brown person take some mysterious powder
onto a plant it happens all the time no
it doesn't yeah
really yeah gwen all did it i'm pretty
sure shout out
with whom his dad no way yeah
wow
oh that's fire
i'm going though if she doesn't do it
i'll do it
i'll spread them yeah that got to be a
dirty ass river though
where do they let you on fire i want to
go there you get cremated right there
say again yeah you get cremated what do
you mean like right there they're not
lighting them on fire and then just pull
up the anthony bourdain episode
right there in these giant pyres and
then they're put into the river and then
he was on the other side getting the
ash's
face from some
wild i haven't seen that but it's like a
wild like
cast of the show am i wrong they light
you on fire there right in india now in
america you go to a funeral house you
have the funeral food home whatever and
then you get cremated
like that's it yeah i don't know it's
wild but why you want to go full casket
yep why it's super lit and are you good
why why i want to pick out the outfit
and everything
because i'm taking that wherever i go
okay or if i run it back
like you don't know if we could run this
back that's a good point so yeah i wanna
even if it's bones dude
yeah yeah well if you run it back you
you're not going to wear the same
clothes in your next life no but they'll
they'll have an idea what i like
anything god knows that already yeah
it's assuming it's god but what if it's
a simulation you know what i mean like
what if it's the aliens
do you think they know that already
no
they're busy man they've got a lot of
other things going on
is your suit also going to be
three-quarter length on the pants yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you